l'italie au bord de l'implosion frappé
de plein fouet par le coronavirus la
péninsule n'arrive plus à suivre le
rythme face aux centaines de migrants
qui continuent d'affluer dans le sud du
pays ce lundi près de 200 migrants se
sont enfuis d'un centre de détention
brisant ainsi la quarantaine qui leur
était imposé en sicile face à ce
comportement
le ministre italien des affaires
étrangères a tenu à souligner
l'importance du respect de tous des
consignes sanitaires
le virus n'est pas derrière nous les
citoyens italiens comme moi doivent
respecter les règles que nous avons
nous-mêmes établi et c'est aussi valable
pour les touristes comme pour ceux qui
bénéficient du droit à la protection
internationale
selon le ministère de l'intérieur la
plupart des migrants ont été retrouvés
mais certains sont toujours en fuite
une situation qui préoccupe les maires
de porto mp doc les élans bezza en
première ligne face aux flux de migrants
la sécurité et la santé des gens sont
les choses les plus importantes et tout
le monde doit y contribuer nous ne
comprenons pas pourquoi porto mp2 clé
est le seul port italien où débarquent
les migrants alerter sur les migrants en
fuite
et quand je suis venu sur place j'ai vu
une mère et son enfant partir dans une
ambulance un centre comme celui ci
conçue exclusivement pour être
provisoire pour un transfert rapide ne
peut pas être utilisé pour un long
séjour
aujourd'hui comme nous sommes toujours
confrontés aux covic 19
les gens ont tellement peur que
lorsqu'ils voient un migrant marcher
dans la rue est cela devient un problème
d'ordre public
la preuve c'est que je reçois
constamment des appels chaque fois que
le centre pour migrants est plein et que
quelqu'un sort et son échappe ou dhr
pour mieux contrôler les flux migratoire
en méditerranée
le gouvernement italien a récemment
accordé des fonds aux gardes-côtes
libyens
une décision qui a suscité l'indignation
des ong et groupes de défense des droits
de l'homme ces derniers ont manifesté ce
lundi à rome
il accuse le gouvernement italien de
complicité dans le trafic d'être humains
et la torture les soi-disant garde-côtes
sont une entité para militaires et para
criminels qui fait partie de
l'organisation sophistiqué de traite des
êtres humains qui contrôle les vagues de
migrants méditerranée et j'estime qu'au
nord du fleuve des migraines méditer
quelques bagarres et injuste que la
politique du gouvernement italien et des
autres gouvernements européens visent
uniquement à stopper les vagues
d'immigration sans vraiment se soucier
de la condition et des droits des
personnes qui veulent traverser la
méditerranée au cours des derniers mois
nous avons trouvé trois dépouilles dans
la mer et de nombreux autres fois nous
avons été témoins de rejet illégaux vers
la libye effectuée avec le soutien des
autorités italiennes et maltaises
l'italie tire la sonnette d'alarmé face
à ces flux difficile à contenir
ce mercredi les garde-côtes italiens ont
déclaré avoir secouru une centaine de
migrants en détresse au large de la
libye
aucun autre pays compétent n'aurait
voulu intervenir